- This is so me.
Nice to see you.
- Kelly, good to see you.
- Come on over.
Oh, my gosh, I love this New
York moment we're having.
- Well.
You switch it up.
I can't wear heels anymore, you know?
- I can't either, I do
not, unless I'm being
paid a lot of money.
- Girl, t's just not happening.
- [Kelly] Yes, I'm with you, I'm with you.
- But this is so New York,
we're celebrating New York.
This is like Working
Girl central right here.
- You got it.
- [Kelly] This is like the movie.
(Kelly laughs)
(crowd applause)
- [Kelly] I love it.
- I used to be able to run in these.
- [Kelly] Oh gosh.
- Yeah I mean, she used
to chase politicians,
you know, through the Capitol.
- You bet.
- That sounds like hell.
You're now the longest
running daytime host ever.
(crowd applause)
- I mean.
- He's the goat.
- Exactly, the goat.
- The goat.
- [Kelly] I know, challenge accepted.
- Kelly, just hang around long enough.
- I'm like, challenge accepted,
i'm very competitive.
- And by the way, i'm a little upset,
because if you would have started
your show, one year later,
- [Kelly] Okay.
you would not have won
the Emmy against me.
And I would have won the Emmy.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Steve] All you had
to do was wait a year.
- That was so rude of me.
- So rude.
- [Kelly] It was so rude.
- Did they have an award
for longest show running?
I mean, that's, that's amazing.
- Yeah I know, it's.
- [Kelly] It's a lot of work.
- It's called assisted living,
that's what it's called.
(Kelly laughs)
- Well.